inutile d'avoir la main verte ce samedi
à plaisir tout le monde était le
bienvenu pour planter un arbre dans le
cadre de l'opération une naissance un
arbre nous nous étions engagés à ce que
nous plantions un arbre parents fort né
à plaisir et donc voilà on est dans
cette démarche là qui est une démarche
bien sûr tournés vers les enfants mais
vers la nature et on a ouvert sa à
l'ensemble des plaisirs ouah c'est mon
petit dernier qu'insiste et pour venir
voilà après on est très fort être à
balade en forêt puis je pense qu'il a
été bien sensibilisés à l'école on est
venu ici ce matin pour planter des
arbres pour la nature et sensibiliser
les enfants aux justement à l'écologie
développement durable et respecter leur
planète une opération qui vise à créer
des îlots de fraîcheur favorisant
l'augmentation de la biodiversité avec
54% des espaces verts la ville de
plaisir compte sur ce dispositif pour
boiser ces coins de nature en créant des
micros fort et on est en train de
recréer un petit écosystème de forêts
naturelles de notre de la région des
yvelines donc on a été répertorié des
essences des arbres et arbustes qui
vivent dans les forêts naturelles de
notre région principalement forêt de
sainte apolline et dans la boucle de
seine également de quoi ravir les
enfants déjà bien sensibilisés à
l'environnement on creuse on prend un
trou et on est un arbre de dans les
graines dedans
ggd pas encore planté et à fréha à
prélever de l'eau après ou se faire
à mesure du temps quand on plante un
arbre on dit toujours qu'on s'en
souvient toute sa vie voilà c'est
vraiment en fait un acte tourner vers
d'espérance en fait planter un arbre
c'est un acte d'espérance tourné vers
l'avenir à la fin de la plantation
chaque enfant a reçu un diplôme de
participation d'autres zones seront
déterminés au sein de la ville pour de
futures plantations plus de 10 milliards
devraient être plantés à plaisir dans
les années à venir